[Music]
ok everyone I am super honored and
excited today to talk to the living
legend Rob Huebel
aka Leo on the show I know this much is
true you might know him from the past on
human giant or recently on medical
police Rob how are you doing today I'm
hanging in there man
I think this pandemic is is not fun for
people but but I'm trying to make the
best of it how are you doing I'm doing
good man and I think what is really
important about your role in this show I
know this much is true is in such a
somber show your character has a lot of
humor to it and comic relief which i
think is much needed I also think that
it's interesting because it's a very
complicated character in Leo because we
see an episode 2 when he's working at
this used car dealership and he's giving
this idea to Dominic - basically soo
Hatch and use blackmail with the picture
of the balls but that he would sue them
even if they released his brother
and that's when Dominic's like oh of
course you would do that and you're like
in a heartbeat so we also see though at
that same scene later on that you're
saying you'd visit Thomas and you do
such a nice gesture to your best friend
and Dominic so did you find it
challenging to play a character that
like has to be sleazy in a way but also
comes off very likeable that's funny
then you describe him that way yeah I
mean I think he's just like you said I
think he's like a hustler you know I
think that's kind of a shitty job you
know selling cars and he doesn't want to
be doing that he's kind of stuck working
there because his father-in-law runs the
car dealership you know he's just sort
of trapped but he really wants to
audition for stuff and you know do
acting stuff but I'm pretty good at
playing sleazy people I sort of that's
sort of my that's sort of my forte but I
think with with Leo the trick with that
is not to really make him sleazy because
I don't think domina
would be friends with a guy that's just
sleazy I think he's more just like you
know he's like a Salesman you know he's
just like one of those guys it's a
little bit slick maybe but I think in
Episode two you saw a little bit of
humanity and you know just a just a hint
of like oh this is a real guy and he
actually has a history with Dominic and
they go way back and he knows Thomas
from from way back also so yeah I think
that was just sort of like a nice moment
between those characters to show a kind
of long friendship that they've been
through a lot of [ __ ] together and Leo
sort of knows what he's going through
you know so he's trying to kind of you
know offer any kind of help or support
that he can that's what you say that and
I like your description there about more
of it being slick than sleazy per se and
it's interesting because I wonder when
you're playing this character you play
it so well are you getting the character
of Leo directly from the book it's based
on or did you kind of find it somewhere
else you got inspired well you know
Derek Cianfrance directed the whole
series and he's just like the I mean
total sidebar but he's just the coolest
guy and like really allows actors the
space and the time to do whatever they
need to do and like I'll give you an
example like I didn't know Ruffalo at
all I had never met him he's friends
with some friends of mine but I didn't
know him and I was nervous to meet him
you know it's the [ __ ] Incredible
Hulk so Derek but Derek wanted you know
us to have this history together in sort
of a shorthand in the way that we talk
to each other and you know so the
conversation just kind of flows
naturally and you talk over each other
and stuff like that so anyway Derek had
me come to New York early where we
filmed it like a week early and just
hang out with Ruffalo so like you know
marked mark came to my hotel and like
picked me up and we just drove around
for a long time talking about stuff and
then there's a scene in episode 3 I
think that he mentioned where we're
playing racquetball well mark and I
don't know how to play
racquetball like I don't know if anyone
knows how to play racquetball anymore
that was like kind of popular I was a
popular pastime I think in the 80s but I
don't know if there's a lot of people
that are still you know haulin ass over
to the racquetball court
so so Derek wanted us to but he wanted
us to be really good like he didn't want
us to be bad you know this was
supposedly something that we did
together in our in our off time so same
thing he had us like come to set like a
few days early and like go to this
racquetball club in New York and learn
to play with this like instructor and
you know we're both terrible like I
think we both like we're just flailing
around the court but you know after some
practice I think we got ok at it right
and I think it's kind of a you know it's
all going to be how they edit it they
shoot it from a million different angles
so they can kind of edit it to make you
look good
you know when we're not really back that
that good but I think the point I'm
trying to make is that Derek just really
has he's a real stickler for things
feeling totally natural and totally real
and he doesn't really want it to seem
like you're asking at all so he wants
you to kind of like experience you know
whatever the scene is there was a scene
I mean this is not funny at all but
there was a scene in last week's episode
just a very quick scene of the funeral
of Dominic in Dez's you know baby that
that died in the crib
and so there's a there's a real quick
flashback and it's probably like 30
seconds on the screen well when we shot
that Derek had the entire congregation
of that church like a real church come
to the church that day fill the church
had a real priest and a real altar boy
do a real do a real funeral and they
just like didn't stop like dick Derek
didn't say action or cut he just said
start the funeral you know and they
started doing the funeral and so you're
sitting there as an actor and at first
you're like well this is kind of weird
and then like a few minutes then you're
like oh wow this is really sad and then
about a minute later you're like oh my
god so you know you can't help but get
emotional because you're at a funeral
for a child right yeah so my point is
Derek just loved that sort of
authenticity and will do anything to
make it seem real and so so that's the
kind of stuff that he does and I've
never worked that way before I've never
worked with anyone like that before
and it was so cool and so different so I
think that's kind of what helps make the
show so special it seems really
authentic and emotional and genuine and
that's because most of the schemes are
like he would set it up so that you are
actually experiencing that scene you
know as realistically as possible so
you're telling me that you're really
going one-on-one with Mark Ruffalo and
racquetball here like are you a better
player than him would you say I mean I
don't want to start an internet war if
it's the Hulk but yeah you can yeah I
would put that out there I'm comfortable
in saying that I dominated the court I
Tom and I would say that with a capital
v dominated okay and you're and you're
telling me that's a real sweat that was
just drenching your shirt that wasn't
any effects or anything
totally real sweat on me on mark of
course they have to bring in the sweat
spray you know the glycerin you know
they have to like make him look sweaty
not me bro I was so speaking to about
how Derek directs you and the whole cast
and just sets the scene I wonder when I
really love some of your humorous lines
here in episode 2 when you say to
Dominik that you're auditioning for a
horror film now and that you're the lead
detective and that there's Christian
teenagers being murdered and then you go
on and say he lives like [ __ ] and
basically told me looks like a basset
hound how much of this is improv or how
much is if it's like - the script like
does he give you guys room to do that
yeah I just improvise that part like you
know you you know he has a script that
he wrote but you know taken from the
book so I think Derek I'm not sure you
got that him how he wrote it but I
assuming he went through the book and
adapted all of those scenes and cut them
down and kind of reworked some parts but
you know the way I I kind of assumed
that when I'm hired because my
background is an improviser I assume
that when I'm hired most directors want
me to kind of do that a little bit at
least so I usually try to do exactly
what they have on the script the first
few times so we get that and then I'll
just start veering off into like weirdo
land and saying kind of whatever I want
and so it's fun it's fun for me because
it keeps it different and I think it's
fun for mark because it gives him
something to react to and then Mark's
improvising also you know like but that
goes back to what I was saying that that
Derek likes is he just wants it to seem
like oh these are just two people
talking that know each other so I'm not
waiting for mark to finish his line
before I talk like we're just talking
over each other he's reacting to what
I'm saying so yeah I think I made that
up
I think in the script it said that I was
auditioning for a movie like an
independent movie and so I said that a
few times and then I just changed it up
to a horror movie and I just sort of
threw in the thing that these are that I
was the lead detective and these are
christian teens that are being murdered
so yeah you know it's just like just
trying to be specific and weird
yeah no it's it's perfect and I wondered
too watching this I think what got me
excited about when you're posting about
being in the show it's always
interesting because I kind of look at
your roles in this show and also in
transparent where there is like a good
amount of serious you're playing - and I
wonder yeah you would ever consider if
someone came do you want to do a full
serious role like that's something you
see in your future you'd want to tackle
oh yeah no doubt I think it'd be really
fun I mean it's really scary to me to do
super serious stuff you know like I'm
really comfortable like transparent it
was sort of like the perfect job for me
because it's so real and grounded and
emotional but I could also improvise a
lot in that and
the you know sort of be in that every
now you know like that show is really
about family also it's just about a very
complicated family and so yeah I love
that sort of stuff you know that I think
the sweet spot for me is something where
I can be serious but also you know throw
in some some comedy every now and then
but with a straight face you know like
that I like being the funny guy in a
Drama you know like we're sort of like
with sarcastic weirdo guy you know like
I think that's that's a great spot to be
if it was just like straight up like I
don't know that I could do what Ruffalo
Pope is doing russello is doing
something that is like next-level
like that is so intense and so layered
you know and I'm sure you know you know
he gained all this weight or no first he
lost all this weight and then they you
know filmed one side of him and then he
went away for six weeks and and gained
all this weight to play Thomas right and
so you know that's that's intent but but
he's just doing the I think the most
incredible acting like that I've seen in
a long time I should also just very
quickly give a shout out to the guy who
you will not see in the movie well you
might see him for I think they gave them
another smaller scene but um mark is
acting you probably know this already
but mark is acting opposite a guy that
they replaced digitally this guy named
Gabe Fazio you should talk to him you
can find him on Instagram Gabe did this
actor that played Thomas the whole time
when Mark was being Dominic and then
turned around and played Dominic when
Mark had to be Thomas and so it gave
mark someone to react to and do his
scenes with you know so all of that
emotion that you're seeing in mark is
being given to you know buy this other
actor who you don't see
just replaced you know they replace them
digitally or you know they just cut him
out
so he's not in that he's not in it you
know alright so but the the guys just
like a really cool guy and a great actor
and it's like I thought that was a
really neat sort of Easter egg about the
show is that there's this other guy out
there you don't even see because he's
been he's been edited out of the movie
you know yeah it's like he's a complete
unsung hero and it's really cool you
know make him a song here are now and
like I just think to rob like I do think
you can act that level of Ruffalo you
wonder why because that Instagram video
you posted with reacting to the
Thunderbirds giving you the middle
finger and that crying you were doing I
was like this guy this guy but let me
just say my final question for you is
basically I grew up on human giant I
think it's shaped some of my odd humor
in my head and especially my favorite
sketch you ever did was being jealous of
the whale at SeaWorld
that was just terrible and I see you can
say when I yelled at the whale you swim
in my face oh yeah oh my god funny and
it just showed me really just where you
could go in comedy and was so fresh and
awesome and I see you're posting a lot
of behind-the-scenes clips of human
giant on Instagram so I do want to ask
it'd be silly if I didn't but is there
ever a chance we get another sort of
reunion of human giant down the road
[Laughter]
like ten years ago and I was like
suddenly I have like hundred videos and
photos I've just kind of gone crazy we
closely messed up but in the answer is I
don't know I would love to do that we've
actually talked about cheer and I were
sort of just messing around and saying
you know we should do a reunion on zoom'
it was like mr. show just did that and I
thought that that was super funny and
I'm such a fan of all those guys so we
were saying you know we should do a
reunion on zoom' I think
I haven't talked to him in a little bit
I think he's living in London but and
then the real sort of speed bump right
now is that our director Jason Wallner
just had a baby and so I don't think
he's in the mood right have to [ __ ]
around on unzoom with us you know I
think he's dealing with the baby and not
getting any sleep but but who knows my
answer is who knows maybe we maybe we
can get it organized I would love to do
it yeah that's that's exciting just to
hear that's a great answer of Rob thank
you so much for joining me today I
really appreciate it everyone please
make sure to check out Rob in medical
police on Netflix it's currently on
there and also I know this much is true
every Sunday 9:00 p.m. on HBO and you
can also get it on the HBO Go app Rob is
there anything else you want to plug no
man I really appreciate you I think you
covered all my bases for me and I thank
you so much for for watching the show
and for for being a fan of comedy and
good television yeah man I can't wait to
hear your first Emmy speech coming up
it's going to be great okay thanks buddy
how's it going